it is unrelenting this is kharkiv a city
that is endured almost constant Russian
attacks in the nearly year-long War
I was in my bed and I was thinking
thinking thinking and suddenly a strong
force woke me up I flew out of bed right
into the kitchen Hawa was not killed I
do not know
Ukraine's President Vladimir zielinski
has urged allies to speed up the
delivery of weapons especially
long-range missiles
it would be possible to stop this
Russian Terror if we could provide our
military with adequate missiles so the
terrorists do not have a sense of
impunity Ukraine needs long-range
missiles in particular to remove the
possibility of the occupier placing its
missile launches far from the front line
and Destroy Ukrainian cities with them
in Carson in the South a hospital was
among the buildings hit
Ukrainian troops retook the city in
November and Russian troops withdrew to
positions across the donipro river
but the bombardment has continued the
last few days have seen intensive
shelling there is no respite for the
people here
Natasha gname Al Jazeera